[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nos gouvernements nous mentent sur
l'état de l'urgence climatique et écologique
il est temps d'agir et il est
temps que le public australien
puisse comprendre le message que notre
gouvernement ne nous dit pas pour  leurs
propres intérêts
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que cela nous amène plus loin
Je ne serai jamais opposé à ce que quelqu'un
puisse exprimer son opinion et
exprimer sa voix mais empêcher
les gens de pouvoir aller faire leur  le
travail quotidien ne nous rapproche pas nécessairement de
l'action climatique que
cette pièce
[Music]
nous ne voulons pas être perturbateurs, nous
voulons juste l'action climatique mais rien d'autre n'a
fonctionné jusqu'à présent
[Music]
vous